- Are you okay?
Oh my God, please don't bite me.
I'm so sorry.
(polka music)
- I just hope the dog likes the bath
because I don't want it
to be scared. (laughing)
- I have given a cat a bath before,
and it was an awful experience.
So, I'm kind of just hoping this
is a little bit better than that.
- [Interviewer] Does anyone
have any last thoughts
before you meet the dog?
- It's three of us against one,
so I think we can do this. (laughing)
- We'll be fine.
- Yeah.
(intense acoustics)
- Oh, hi.
Hi.
- He's really nice.
I'm just like not really
sure how to handle dogs.
- I guess we're gonna
give a dog a bath now.
- Aw, he looks so scared.
- Aww.
- I know.
- It kind of looks like
he's taking a shower
- Yeah, look at him go.
- Are you into this?
He's so slippery.
- Alright. Let's get that little poof.
(water splashing)
- He's kind of a rat.
- Oh, perfect.
Yeah, if you could just
face that way. (chuckling)
Wow.
(soft jingles)
- I'm soaking.
- Oh, no.
Slippery.
- [Interviewer] Okay, Danielle,
can you put him back in?
(water pouring)
- You're, so clean
(dog shaking water)
(group sighs)
- Just when we started to like you.
Alright, here we go.
Okay, maybe my lap's
probably not the best idea. (laughing)
- It wasn't as bad as I
thought it was going to be.
He was really chill.
- Spencer here is a really good boy,
and I'm very happy I
got to give you a bath,
out of all the dogs in the world.
- I actually really
connected with this dog.
- I'm like smelling him now,
and I feel like we didn't
do that good of a job,
but that might just be the wet dog.
- That's wet dog
- I just don't really know dogs that well.